hey there I'm Christopher Meloni I'm
here at BuzzFeed promoting happy
exclamation point first time I have a
beer though okay now that we're done
with that because they did a quick edit
let do first tweets here we go
[Music]
question what does Christopher Meloni
own answer my entire ass yeah was
renting for a while but it just wasn't
worth it so I decided to go whole whole
whole hog in buy it please don't post
pictures of Christopher Meloni I will
get too horny uh-huh what does that mean
how does that manifest itself to horny I
want to watch happy but at the same time
I know I won't be able to handle how
goddamn hot Christopher Meloni is I know
join the rest of America you ever stop
and remember naked Christopher Meloni on
Oz because I do would lick ranch
dressing off Christopher Melones
forehead you spelled forehead wrong
actually I think it's weird not to have
sex dreams about Christopher Meloni sent
us my wife oh no it's the opposite way
red she'd never has I'd cut off my arm
to touch Christopher Melones but it's
that serious that is serious
but then what would you do with the arm
I want one of those big wallpaper murals
people have of florists but instead it's
just christopher meloni naked in the
shower or something once you have that
design of a picture of something
christopher meloni is what I imagined
when I say I want a thick daddy and
that's a double C on the thick this
person means business this person knows
thing this person probably actually uses
the word fat pH eighty they want what
they want who's got eyes on Christopher
Meloni
I haven't seen his ass in a while and I
need to make sure he's good and thriving
now is he referring to my ass or is it
me am i good
driving with my ass attached to me
everything's fine
thanks for your concern when I'm sad I
just google Christopher Melones but
until I'm not sad anymore I think that's
why Google was invented and maybe my
weekend [ __ ] but you have to wear this
christopher meloni mask the entire time
and make the bumbum sound from lawn
order when you are there christopher
meloni mask on sale these are some sexy
tweets people got it back
[Applause]